what do you get when you put together
rubber gloves rain boots LED lights and
a cake saver you get a hitchhiking robot
hello would you like to have a
conversation
meet dr. Frogg zelner and David Harris
Smith hello hello they're the creators
of hitch but my name is hitchbot which
is hitchbot a hitchhiking robot that
hitchhikes around the country and is
dependent on the help of strangers so
this DIY robot had a mission to
hitchhike across Canada from Halifax all
the way to Victoria we wanted people to
help the robot to really see in this
project
how far will people go not just take a
robot in the car but also helping it
usually it's humans who are scared that
robots will take over the world well
these guys flip that idea on its head
the main question laws can robots trust
humans and with one thumb in the air the
International sign for Lemmy hitch a
ride hitchbot started its journey across
Canada it quickly captured hearts and
minds in Canada and beyond we heard from
many people that they would start their
day with a cup of coffee and opening up
the hitch bot website to see where it
had been on the map it's but was getting
the kind of quintessential Canadian
experience by heading off for a camping
trip in the gaspé Peninsula
it had ferry rides and went to the First
Nations powwow really kind of diverse
cultural experience that really span the
country take each bot under a month and
a dozen and a half helpers to travel
3,800 miles across Canada I had just
recently moved to Canada when we started
the project I was taken aback by how
helpful and enthusiastic they were about
this little robot basically
was wonderful to see the community
spirit that was build and that's the
story of how one robot hitchhiked across
Canada
you
[Music]